si vous aimez les petits plats
économiques vite préparés et qui à eux
tout seul font un repas complet cette
recette locale avait Renaise doit vous
intéresser son nom la tourtière au
salsifis et à la saucisse et c'est une
habitante d'un petit bourg plaisance
d'Aveyron Yvette Sabatier qui nous la
présente
alors cette pâte c'est une pâte commence
vous l'avez vous avez donc fait une pâte
pour couvrir la croustade de la saucisse
des salsifis salsifis un oeuf un œuf ça
c'est pour le doré donc apparemment des
apparemment c'est tout
ce que vous faites alors je nettoie les
salsifis je vais bien les laver avec de
l'eau vinaigrée je vais le blanchir avec
un petit peu de farine
et je les laisse cuire une heure
[Musique]
voilà
je vais mettre un cuire une heure
voilà alors je vais mettre mes salsifis
à frire
alors je mets un peu de un peu de poivre
un peu de sel
je vais bien de feu
le 5e figurines je vais couper la
saucisse préparer
pour combien de personnes pour six
personnes
je prends la pâte
je vais mettre mes salsifis
[Musique]
j'ajoute un peu de jus de volaille
c'est du jus de volaille
je fais un petit pour que la cuisse
sorte et vous avez même pensé à la
décoration vous êtes une artiste
voilà c'est pas la cuisson
à mon four assez chaud 30 minutes
voilà
ça peut se manger aussi bien chaud que
froid
[Musique]
alors à servir avec un bon martial